[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 104 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Mac mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Weirich yes it's good
to be here it's good to be here nice and
early in the morning but this week we're
having a really great conversation with
Eric Anderson talking all about data
prep and all about how you can get your
messy data clean especially when you
have lots of it
yes he's gonna definitely touch on the
values of what you can use data prep for
and one of the things he covers is how
it could be useful for future
engineering which it's gonna be our
question at the end of the interview to
talk about what is feature engineering
but first what we want to get to is the
cool things of the week and to start off
our cool things of the week last week we
were talking about performance analysis
one thing we want to share is that
Google is actually making Intel
performance libraries freely available
on Google cloud platform the good thing
about this is that is actually allowing
the Intel Zenon scalable skylake
processors more performant I get to say
that a lot cool so I guess if you're
doing this is something outside of my
purview but I guess if you're doing
Python based scientific programming this
seems like the sort of thing that you'd
be interested in I think so in terms of
what it can be useful for for sure but
it's just the idea of being able to make
your processors more performant at the
end of the day like it's great to have a
fast chip but if you can't actually run
it as fast as it should be then that's a
problem for our second cool thing of the
week as actually a couple of articles
kind of join together starting with an
article written by a David mitten you
may recognize that name as the CEO of
silver density we had them on the
podcast or him specifically on the
podcast episode 69 talking about how
they use Google cloud platform he has a
really cool article way he refers to it
as the hidden cost of cloud it's a
really interesting article talking about
basically how if you're moving from say
something that's probably more of a
rented VPC or a VPS I mean or maybe
running around data centers the
differences in costs that can occur when
you're moving to the cloud and how you
can mitigate that and basically watch
what's happening with that and what's
kind of cool is reading that is we
literally just put
that the export for cloud platform
billing from the export to that's
bigquery just went GA so if you want to
dig deeper into how your billing is
working especially across products
across projects it is a really nice tool
for doing that and there's links in the
blog post to to basically visualize your
spend over time we've data studio and if
you're not familiar with data studio
it's a great way to visualize your data
that sits inside bigquery and there's
actually a drop in demo that basically
takes your billing data and drops it
straight into data studio with some
really nice pre-built visualizations so
you can see exactly what's going on
inside your billing and see what money
you're spending and where and then you
can extend it from there depending on
how your business is run and your
application needs this is a really great
thing to have considering I know that's
the top of mind priority for most
companies when they're working with
anything around servers so it's good
that they have this type of tool
available or they have this kind of
information available all right so last
thing we wanted to mention was the fact
that taggle is running a competition
where you can basically use tensorflow
for speech recognition they have 65,000
short sound clips that are multiple
people saying 30 different types of
words and the idea is that you in
essence are going to come up with a
model that will help identify what is
being said so that is running for the
next two months
and it's got a price of 25,000 and we're
gonna have a link on our blog that will
help take you to where it's at but I
mean if you just look up Kaggle speech
intensive flow you'll easily find it
this is cool
cackle does some great stye now they do
big fan big fan if nothing else even if
you're not gonna do the challenge it's
kind of great to see the data sets that
they have available to play around with
and experiment with I always tell people
when they ask me how do I get started
with machine learning or where do I get
data from and I'm like go to Carol yeah
that makes a lot of sense awesome
why don't we go have a chat with Eric
and talk all about data prep sounds good
today I am pleased and delighted to have
Eric Anderson product manager for cloud
data prep Eric how are you doing I'm
doing great
thanks for having me actually thanks so
much for joining us I'm super keen to
hear more about data prep it's something
I haven't personally used a lot so
definitely interested in what it is and
what it does but before we do that one
you tell us a little bit about who you
are what do you do at Google everything
about you your 5-year plan just all the
good stuff yeah
so speaking of five years I've been four
years at Google all of it on cloud which
is fairly long time through Google cloud
years let's see I grew up in Salt Lake
City Utah still go back probably
annually spend a little time whitewater
rafting they're a little rugby there but
now I just do computers and hang on the
Bay Area awesome cool so data prep this
is a thing
can you give us like the 30,000 foot
view like what is this product what is
it meant to do sure anyone who's worked
with data has felt the pain of data
preparation we talk a lot about all the
interesting things you can do with data
visualization algorithms analysis and
usually we talk about it on pretty nice
and clean data but and then in the real
world there's friction air resistance
and there's bad data and it's everywhere
so a data prep focuses on that initial
step used to do any kind of data work
which is to get your data in the
position in the in the structure you
know join with the proper datasets that
you want so that you can then go on and
do analysis so it's it's kind of a top
of the funnel first of the workflow
product and when you say data or data
set what does that mean is that mean
like I'm at home working on my
spreadsheet for my taxes or does that
mean something else it could but really
we're talking generally about large data
sets what you might define this big data
presumably these are things that are
hard to see and find all the errors just
visually and so yeah when you can't see
all the data then data prep might be the
thing to help you clean it up so I try
to understand it be more these got like
a filter to basically clean your data
and I understand that concept but what
does it look like to use it data is a
very generic thing mm-hmm what does it
look to clean like I don't know phone
numbers or to clean my credit card
numbers it's completely different and
there's different algorithms involved
with that but what does it mean to clean
the data sure and I'll back up to give
you kind of a mental model and and also
some mental images you're familiar with
spreadsheets everyone is and you can see
your data so yes yeah so bad but good
also so good so you've you've got a
metal like a grid of your data in the
spreadsheet but also some of us may be
familiar with like ETL tooling or other
type of data of tooling with where you
would describe the flow and processing
steps in which case you're not looking
at your date at all you're just looking
at the transformations or steps that are
done to change your data that equally
valid approaches but in the case of the
latter you know the ETL tooling or when
you see a diagram with the
transformation steps it's hard to know
exactly what your data looks like at any
point in time you can see what the logic
being applied to it but you don't know
if that logic is being applied and the
way you want it if you're getting inputs
and outputs expected so what we've done
is it's kept you in kind of the
spreadsheet paradigm so with data prep
you're looking at a grid of your data
but because you can't see all of your
data at the same time we've added
additional visual elements to give you
the sense of the complete data set so we
sample data so you're looking at a
representative sample we apply some
visual distributions atop each column
give you a sense for the distribution of
columns we also detect type and and
provide some validation on those types
again to give you while you can't see
little column you can see outliers you
can see anomalies using these visual
cues so you talking about
messy data or cleaning data like what
does that mean I just assume that all
data sets are perfect aren't they sure I
mean it's not like they're always
erroneous and do sets might be fine for
one situation and not so clean or fine
for another situation we're all probably
familiar of like somewhat erroneous data
like outliers or anomalies that aren't
representative you can imagine
transaction information and and people
make returns or improper transactions I
mean using like point-of-sale for
example information if you want to use
that as an example not everything that
passes through the register is something
that you want to track perhaps as a as
an analyst and so yeah a part of it
might be cleaning and removing those
erroneous or anomalies but there might
be other things done as part of
preparation enrichment or joining is
fairly obvious and straightforward you
know you may have it's very common to
have several different data sources
that you want to combine into a single
fully enriched table as structuring your
data so you have a single column with
fully defined address but it's hard to
filter on States when they're embedded
in the string and so you might want to
parse out a column into several
different columns for example I say so
you may have structuring steps
aggregations also common you know you
have single records perhaps and you want
to aggregate these into daily totals or
an hourly totals these are all things
that can be done in data prep so all of
these steps those sound like something
that you could write yourself is data
prep like a library of filters that are
useful for common data signs or or is it
more than that yes certainly so the
common alternatives might be sequel you
could write if this was like stored in a
sequel compliant database of sorts you
could apply sequel operations to this
another alternative common one would be
Python or other scripting language
there's some great Python libraries
where you can take things as a table or
frame of data and apply transformations
to it both of those cases again you're
not able to see the data itself and
you're not able to see intermediate data
and you're not able to get a kind of a
sense for the full data set at one time
there are certain popular patterns I've
used myself I should say like data
scientist or data analyst we'll have a
cocktail of common queries and/or
scripts that they'll throw it a new data
set you know describe columns show me
the distributions of each column so
we've kind of packaged all those common
tasks into a single view and in addition
to just showing you the view of your
data we can then let you transform it
and without having to write scripts so
if you're very familiar in Python or
sequel you might be productive but even
then we find that even Python and sequel
experts find themselves really
productive in data prep so yeah in
addition to just viewing your data you
can also create transformations in some
case no code transformations there's an
interesting I'll just jump right into
how that's possible we talked about the
distributions and the anomaly detection
variety those visual cues selecting
those visual cues
we'll select the subset of data that
applies and then will suggest data prep
will suggest in kind of like real time
likely transformations to apply to that
subset so if we showed you a bunch of
states and 10% of those states were not
actual states there were territories the
United States or something and you
wanted to you select those we might
suggest you remove them we might suggest
you do other parsing steps on them and
then you can choose that transformation
so you've gone from explore and
understand my data to remove some
anomalies without writing any code this
has just been like reactive gestures to
the interface so not only is data prep
by goo ease so that you can visualize
your information there's also some nice
machine learning behind the scenes or
something like that
to basically give you suggestions on
ways you could make your data possibly
quote-unquote right right yeah and you
know you're the only judge of better but
we've learned her from experience what
or the algorithms learn from experience
what is likely to be interesting to you
and we serve you up several options and
you pick from those cool so what does it
look like to use data prep how do you
get the data into it or out of it
because at the end it really feels like
you're basically improving the data so I
see it as a pipe sure yeah of like a
bigger process how do you connect it to
other things the integration points for
data prep are through GCS and bigquery
so we accept all the standard file
formats you might expect us to on GCS
and then we accept bigquery tables we'd
like to expand that over time but we've
actually found that this solves you know
the 90% use case for TCP users is this
is this like a one-time thing or is this
something that could be put in a
pipeline of ongoing streaming data the
thing we want to solve really well
initially is is the necessarily the
one-time experience and and we're
delivering on that and that's something
that's been pretty exciting to us but as
soon as you saw something one-time as an
analyst or as a scientist or whoever
most people then want to you know they
want to schedule that thing to run all
the time or or check that into
production and so we are in the process
of adding those features scheduling is
as soon to arrived allow you to schedule
that execution to happen on some time
basis and then eventually we want to
support the ability to
programmatically execute those
transformations by other means cool so I
was watching a video on data prep and it
looks really cool and now I get a little
bit more than a of like it really looks
like a super-powered spreadsheet it's
really cool but also one of the things
that I saw was when you click on run job
you see cloud dataflow yeah what is the
relationship between cloud dataflow and
cloud better prep great yeah great
question we're pretty excited about that
relationship so for those of you who
don't know dataflow is a massively
parallel data processing service and/or
framework depend on how you look at it
and it so it's very powerful it's it's
based on technology we've been
developing at Google for a long time in
MapReduce flume etc so to have data flow
your fingertips is awesome but a lot of
people aren't ready to use data flow
through it's also expressive and
powerful API is currently Java and
Python are supported and data prep what
it allows you to do is to express these
things in an intuitive visual way using
data prep and then you can know that
even though I'm having a great
spreadsheet experience that behind the
scenes I'm gonna have also an awesome
massively parallel powerful processing
experience so when you hit run job we
take the logic that you've generated on
the sample using either predicted
transformations or your own custom
transformations we package that logic
and pass it to data flow and data flow
creates a job that reads from your
source and writes to your destination
with all the processing logic you define
then it feels like once you have that
running Cloud dataflow one of the cool
things is that you can run it as a batch
process or you can also run it as
something that is continuously running
and as soon as you get some input you
get the output on the other side is that
it's possible with cloud data prep like
you basically be fine
continuously running dataflow job and
then you can just send things into the
input and get the clean version on the
other side yeah continuously running is
something that's never really been done
in the frame of data preparation
industry if you wanna call that or
landscape data preparation has always
been kind of a batch thing what's neat
about where we're at today with data
prep yes it's it's batch only today but
it is you know because we
data flow we are submitting beam
pipelines and the beam program model
allows both batch and streaming so it be
natural evolution for us to go into
streaming in the future and that's
something I think would be super
exciting and we've heard some requests
from that from our users so actually the
probably segues into a nice question
when should a customer choose either
data prep or data flow it sounds like
there is crossover there streaming seems
like an obvious choice because data flow
but are there other features there that
may make one someone choose one over the
other yeah sure so I'll start with send
me the obvious input if you want to
comment limitations what one way to
think about it is that data flow is it
kind of just supports almost anything
it's a programming interface so that you
can do almost do anything with data flow
even things that maybe you shouldn't do
with data flow where data prep provides
you it's a constrained I should describe
that we have your transformations create
kind of script steps and we use a human
readable script within data prep the bin
is translated into the beam SDK so yeah
because we're using a DSL on beam there
certainly were constrained to to the
limits of that DSL which is fairly
expressive and we actually think it's
more expressive than sequel so you
should have plenty of room to grow there
but yeah currently today for example you
couldn't pass arbitrary code to data
prep for that type of use do you want to
bounce out to data flow and do
everything there it is possible to of
course cheney's into a workflow because
we're reading and writing from common
sources GCS and bigquery you could
combine data flow and data prep into
sequence pipelines but more to the
comparison so yeah if you prefer a
visual environment if you prefer a human
readable script language data preps
great place for you if you prefer the
expressiveness of a programming language
and or maybe some of the like data
engineering processes around a
programming language you know if you
want to write unit tests if you want to
write other kind of tests data flow and
a programming language is the right
place for you is there any limitation on
what sort of data formats data prep can
handle obviously you've got bigquery but
if you said GCS like right I didn't put
anything I went into GCS so yeah so we
take like text formats you know we're
gonna be able to like open most things
but we're limited to a handful of
formats in which we understand the
structure so like an Avro CSV JSON these
are all supported there's a few others
actually Excel files are also supported
we should add sheets to that list so
it's not there yet
and then I was gonna mention like for
example XML isn't supported although
it's like it's similar to JSON and a
semi structured file format you'll be
able to read XML but you won't be able
to come in as a structured format like
the same way that we do JSON for example
cool so what I would love to know is if
people are interested in data prep or
they seem like this is interested what's
a great resource they can go to to learn
more about it sure and actually also
give you at some point some like where
we're at and our kind of timeline and
launch and that sort of thing resources
so we have a QuickStart available and
Doc's available the QuickStart is like I
would give you some sample data and
suggest some transformations if you're
familiar with the Google cloud platform
code labs there's actually already a
couple set up some of them are designed
for using data prep in the context of
machine learning which is something we
can discuss them and there's a bit a
couple blogs out there it's still
nascent I'm gonna go ahead and jump into
where we're at kind of in our rollout we
announced data prep that with the you
know that we were working on this
originally in the spring at Google cloud
next 2017 and it was then in a what we
called a private alpha release for some
time or private beta release and then we
opened it up to a public beta just a few
weeks ago so now anybody yeah all you
listening can can go find it in the
cloud console among all the other
products what you should look forward to
with some additional feature releases
and a general availability at some point
in the future nice you mentioned data
prep and machine learning machine
learning is the hot word so like what's
what's the connection there just wanna
it has made Beth's words as possible
often we think about data preparation in
the context of business intelligence or
kind of data analyst work in which case
a lot of that work is it can be plumbing
kind of like ETL it can also be a little
more higher level like you're trying to
arrive at some answers and you're
preparing a data set for those answers
but the analysis is fairly
straightforward using straightforward
tools downstream data visualization
simple aggregations in the case of maybe
more advanced machine learning and data
science even those that are you know
very comfortable in Python or or
whatever common machine learning or
rotative Science interface you prefer
we've we've actually found some people
that prefer to jump over to data prep to
do their data preparation so you know in
a machine learning data science workflow
you're gonna take these maybe multiple
data sets and you're gonna combine them
in some way and then you're gonna do
some exploration to make sure that you
you don't have too much noise or
anomalous data and you're also going to
do what we teach your engineering you're
gonna make some assess you know judgment
about what you think are the important
features and you're gonna put those in
unique columns and you might normalize
those columns all in preparation for
then applying your kind of
out-of-the-box algorithms that upstream
work around combining the data set can
be done in data prep the feature
engineering work in fact actually
separating out your the important
features into unique columns and
normalizing them can be done a data prep
if you're familiar with Cagle which is
this machine learning and data science
kind of competition and forum community
one of the big Kaggle users who's won a
few contests was super excited about
data prep and and has been using it in
his cattle worked so there's some
interesting work there just to touch on
the workflow of these people are
probably doing initial work in Python
realizing that they have you know some
data issues or strange behavior and
their algorithms and it might bounce out
today to prep using GCS or bigquery as
an interchange point and they can go
back to their Python environment for
example and pick up the new data sets
that are cleaned cool so seems like
we're running out of time just a little
bit but before we do that we always like
to give our guests an opportunity to
plug anything that they think is
important or if there's something that
we haven't mentioned yet is there
something you want to add to the pocus
make sure it gets in yeah I should plug
that we're really excited we're really
eager to get some feedback on date
prep we've got a lot of positive
responses and with that a bunch of
future suggestions use cases we hadn't
considered and and then that's informing
our roadmap there's a big surface area
at the data prep there's a lot of like
you know bells whistles knobs and so
there's plenty of room to explore and
and suggest new things and places where
we can improve and we'd love to hear
from you quick question
is there so is there any specific way
that people might want to use to provide
that that feedback to you and the team
we'd love to hear from you on Stack
Overflow we monitor Stack Overflow and
we also are soon to introduce a
discussion forum email alias that you
can join in addition to those channels
which are available anyone and there's
common other channels you can go to the
Google cloud meetups and pass
information through channels they're
cool Erik thank you so much for joining
us today and chatting to us all about
data prep hey thanks for having me
thanks Erik the great information about
data prep and data flow now what we want
to do is drive into you the question of
the week so we were chatting before
about the idea of features and feature
engineering in the podcast we did with
Eric and so we were chatting and I don't
know a lot about this space so I figured
I'd ask you Melanie about like what is
the importance of features in regards to
machine learning and like why do we need
to do feature engineering like why is
that a thing
so future engineering has been something
that has been a priority to developing
models of machine learning and it's it's
required a lot of work in the past
particularly it's used to help drive out
or define specific attributes of
properties about the data set that
doesn't necessarily come across with raw
data and it helps you identify what's
more important to help drive the
predictive models at your building like
I said it's something that has required
a lot of manual labor in the past it's
can play you know a large role in terms
of the preparation or lead-up to
developing models but with deep learning
becoming such a popular thing in the
last few years
future engineering in particular has
become something that we see is being
automated through deep learning but the
reality is it's not fully automated for
deep learning it's definitely one of
those things that is still necessary to
do some level of
analysis so to speak and so it's good
that data prep is providing that
opportunity to be able to help with the
future engineering process yeah that's
what it's useful for all right now mark
one other question I'm going to ask for
the week is what are you doing for
Thanksgiving and yes I'm totally I'm
totally asking the Australian and the
state's what are you doing for
Thanksgiving what am i doing
Thanksgiving being probably spending a
lot of time at home gonna catch up with
some friends have some food drink some
wine that kind of thing what are you up
to for Thanksgiving same thing it's nice
to have friends that you can go visit
and not have to get on a plane nice but
speak you've gotta go to plane are you
going anywhere speaking at anything over
the next couple of months and just
summer up maybe going to the nips
conference which is this conference
that's really focused around the machine
learning ai community nice what about
you yeah I'll be at the Montreal
International games limit in December
but other than that yeah things are
coming down for the NS Li you did are
you going to Montreal I'm surprised I
didn't know you were going to Montreal
yeah I'll keep mentioning it every week
I just want people to come say hello if
they they happen to listen the podcast
awesome well Melanie thank you so much
for joining me for yet another episode
of the podcast yes we managed to pull
this one out early in the morning so we
can get this for Thanksgiving period yep
and we'll see you all next week
[Music]